[Music]
so
i need something amazon my favorite
has a facial recognition service oh
scary service
technology yeah well they've been
they've been using this uh and they've
been
helping the government locate missing
and exploited children
so that's mostly what they use it for so
it's called
recognition that was coming on the whole
time
i thought they're known for same-day
shipping they
are but they also have prime um they
have tipped tv shows
on prime i thought they're not known for
not paying their no taxes so they are
they also have alexa uh it says it's
like a robot in your house so it tells
you answers to things i don't think
we're known for like stealing
intellectual property and then just like
copying it from like the little guy
that's alibaba that's that yeah
no no no she's right thank you they did
a script writing thing and they were
basically gonna [ __ ] own your ass
what they're talking about if he says
i'm right then i'm right
it was called amazon it was it was just
alexa is amazon known for stealing from
the little guys
siri is in here all right i didn't hear
any answers um so they have a service
where not
recognition it's spelled with a k oh
yeah that's i don't know how else to let
you know yeah i was like i was kind of
mentally trying to tell you a spell with
a k
i thought you're trying to talk like tim
for a second recognition that's what it
is
what's bruce lee's favorite facial
recognition app
edition horrible okay you have to watch
the different videos
we're so sorry anyway so it's actually a
service that's used for good
but currently they're worried that
the uh government is using it to find
protesters
and charge them or like
do some shady [ __ ] well that was in the
ferguson case i actually looked into
this separately it was that like
randomly ferguson protester protest
leaders
started dying all over the place like
from
like three suicides two car accidents
like
randomly they like were dying he shot
himself 50 times
in the back of the head yeah and then he
threw the gun the guys are suicidal
so we decided themselves yeah yeah so
sad
and that's why they tell you when you're
protesting um if you're going to post
pictures to the media
blur faces of people protesting and then
because then they could unblur it
yeah black yeah okay well uh censor
their faces you could unblur a blur
picture
think about photoshop right you blur you
could sharpen both i'm pretty sure the
porn industry probably like they came up
with that for porn everything
technological advances japanese yeah
good job porn um
yeah porn [ __ ] up on blu-rays though
porn picked hd dvd if you recall i don't
i don't think i'd want to watch people i
have all my my whole porn collections
not just on blu-ray
good job your real estate lady poured
yeah okay so if you're protesting they
say to screenshot your picture
before posting it because the metadata
is attached to the picture so they can
you can source it back to your phone
that you were there but i mean there's
google maps that can already zoom in
like no it's your to your phone your
phone location already done
[ __ ] snowden wears blankets over his
head sometimes when he's on video calls
because he snowed in he is not he is
[ __ ] you guys
not this video don't do that [ __ ] not
this video
geo you're literally me or rn
don't say any more edwards in a pun so
no he puts a blanket over his head
because what is it the they can
in they have images of all the hotel the
interiors of the hotels and all over the
world and they can [ __ ] know where he
is
he doesn't want to get [ __ ] drone
striked or something you do that for
like
uh trafficked people and kids and stuff
too
no what what oh i don't know
traffic is his rap name oh he was
getting it swirling i'm with you i was
i was thinking of different passions we
are
it's going to take a while but we're
going to beat them all i wasn't even
listening to you because i was trying to
get buttons
after when you were talking about the
blankets so i was like i was like okay
blankets i was like oh
did your mind go blank no [ __ ] you
the worst horror movie would just be a
bunch of puns coming up behind
yeah it could happen it could happen
oh no that would be the name of the pun
horror movie [ __ ] i hate it it can
happen
yeah jess is gagging over there and
there's nobody with her
she got ghosts not assault i promise you
no nobody's with her
okay
back to this amazon uh has put in a
one-year
moratorium with congress what's a
moratorium
it's i asked right before this shoe
people
it's nope that's the obituary
crematorium
i don't know i just remember that word
it's a stoppage there's a stoppage
okay it's a stoppage calm down it's just
it's it's a stoppage so they're not
using it for a year
so that they um so that they won't abuse
this power for one year they want to put
in
after a year yeah right so that they
could put in stronger regulations to
govern the ethical use of facial
recognition technology well they passed
ibm again ibm basically uh stopped like
allowing the police to use their um
technology for that like facial
recognition and everything because
they're like that's that's [ __ ] up
so they basically like defunded
everything that they're doing what about
apple apple's always been good at this
[ __ ]
they they stopped the fbi from uh from
hacking into their
their their code whatever they used like
a new ceo
like takes the tim cook's place and then
like they already have all their faces
i wouldn't be surprised if they already
privately made some kind of deal you
never know
that's [ __ ] up i mean we all go to the
[ __ ] target and grocery stores and
[ __ ] they already have
all our faces yeah yeah i post on
instagram every day
yeah facts they have everything every
time you use a photo
right now and we tell people where we
are on instagram
does it piss you off when you have a
face mask on you're trying to open your
phone it won't open your phone it won't
open
i don't even have my facial recognition
on because i'm scared of it oh yeah
i don't even i need to buy the phone
that has fake facial
recognition vehicle records usually [ __ ]
on your phone
yeah i don't have that one let me ask
you this guys how do you
get on the toilet when you have your
phone with you do you have like some
kind of a method that you use
left hand is for iphone i turn it
sideways
oh before i get on the toilet i don't
know why the camera
is to
i don't want them to either see my face
or my dick but the train i'm talking
about why are you thinking
special no it's not that's why i don't
want them how do you go live on accident
wait i'm trying to understand steve it's
okay it's okay it's very quick
okay so when you're transitioning from
standing to sitting on the toilet
i make sure the camera is nowhere
looking at my bucket so you're just
going like this
oh i see jio's my [ __ ] spokesperson i
usually just have it like i put on the
counter
and then i sit down well if you're using
it what if i'm using it
like oh like walk walking up and then
sitting down why are you using
while you're on the toilet while i'm
using it i'm looking at the screen
what i do is i put a tv dinner tray out
oh it's not usually
you told us you eat already i eat white
cheddar cheese
i said i don't eat white cheddar just
said you didn't i just mixed my words up
it's not pointing out my dick because i
have i'm on my squatty potty and so my
knees are my elbows are
nice no no
you'd have to i'd have to be like super
angled it's just it's pointing outwards
you know so that's that's usually what's
going on yeah
i want to look at your date my team yeah
i'll show you later
man taint is gooch you know or is it the
same thing
no gucci is the in between that's what
i'm not tainted what the [ __ ] is
what is this it's a perineum yeah well
yeah what's up we're talking about
so okay my understanding was that taint
is in between a girl's
uh vagina and [ __ ] and gooch is
between the guys ball sack and [ __ ]
i thought gooch was equivalent for taint
just different you know there was only
like this much between
our gucci was slang for gucci
that's what i thought no i mean it's
pretty gucci down there it is gucci down
there
if you press it while you're giving a
[ __ ] they like that
i've never done it i didn't say i like
that
that's great it's great it is good uh
yeah gooch
do you press it like a like you're
ringing a doorbell yeah no
i'm not going to give away my i'm not
going to be away for a thumb forgive me
if you have a vibrator stick every time
that you talk i just find you so cool
and
you usually also wear caesar's palace
robes and [ __ ] and so when you said
gooch i thought you were talking about
how sick some how like rich it was oh
yeah dude it's [ __ ] good
bro oh yeah man the area between my my
nuts and my [ __ ]
[ __ ] goose
no that's just a little bit like good to
know body part term i don't have i don't
think i have a gooch
you do you would you everybody has a
gooch you have a gooch it's probably
really pale
it's not pale it's not it's hairy it's
too
that the white people do where they tan
their [ __ ] thing no
for some reason private parts are not as
white as the rest of us
i mean that's true it's very weird what
color is it cambodian
yeah it's more like you frankly it's
like how he has like a black beard
like his hair is on his face growing
dark like my hair
really yeah isn't it like your genitals
color is like the same as like your
nipple color no because that's like
a little bit darker like the color of
your like your genitalia is like the
same color as your nipple balls the same
color as these guys
oh see that's what i'm saying i have
bright pink nipples bright pink
let's see pink too no you can just
imagine that
your dick is holding it right let's see
never i'll never do it you could do it
literally for
10 hours and i wouldn't but what color
is your dick
my dick is white hmm no it's not it's my
women
it's pink dog like it's like
it's like it's like a it's white it's
mostly like
well it's pink white it's not just white
white white
it's not like definitely not just white
she's pretty tan [ __ ] tan bro
she's certainly burning that's why i
touch anything
she's like a [ __ ] tan bro i'm like
squinting okay
yeah i hear you the first time i ever
took my like my penis out on
on a girl when i was like 13. took your
penis out on a girl
on her you should sleep she was sleeping
and tim like no you know like when you
say you whipped it out on her like you
took it out you know
um she was like okay show me and uh mind
you were 13 is like eighth grade
and i was like wrecked and i took it out
and she tripped out because it was like
to her it was purple
and so she was like oh my god why is it
purple and she [ __ ] tripped out
like she freaked out you know
you gotta show us your dick how did you
calm her down with the erection
huh did you like wait calm down calm
down and you have a [ __ ] stream
oh no i didn't chase after i like i had
to like tuck it away where she ran
she didn't run away but she was like oh
my god it's purple like wait wait wait
it's not that purple you're chasing
after me
well here's the thing about it it was
like it was on like the playground
what's the playground why are you going
to write why are you at a playground
after school there's a child care area
if your parents child can't
come pick you up yet it's just it's an
area where we all hang out
junior i had a playground but how old
was she
she was all my age my age so it was k
through eight all right so that's why
there was no eight
yeah there's an area where all the way
kids if your parents couldn't compete
pick you up right to school
that wasn't were you embarrassed to show
your dick again for a while no because
after that she was like she became my
girlfriend my first girlfriend oh she
was like purple dick purple dick
not did she like the purple dick bro oh
my god did you [ __ ] at 13
no no i was um i know why are you
whipping your dick or not [ __ ]
well we were doing oral stuff until like
four like 14 15.
yeah i didn't do this until 18 25 i
actually didn't i didn't but i didn't
lose my virginity until 18.
yeah wow yeah it was precious to you
kind of yeah saying
yeah no jokes no jokes people are
waiting for something
you